Salut.
Cette vidéo, c'est la première d'une nouvelle série
que j'avais un petit peu commencée
en fin d'année.
Au lieu de vous faire un Master Class
ou de vous donner une astuce concrète
pour savoir faire quelque chose,
je vais plutôt essayer de vous l'expliquer
en l'apprenant à quelqu'un.
Comme ça, ça me permet de détecter aussi
les difficultés d'apprentissage
et vous-même vous voyez que c'est possible
de le faire,
et j'espère que ça vous motivera.
Pour cette première vidéo,
je vais vous apprendre un calendrier perpétuel.
C'est à dire, qu'à la fin,
vous allez être capable de dire
quel jour de la semaine tombe
n'importe quelle date de 2017
ou 2018
ou 2019
ou 2020.
Et je l'ai sûrement mis dans le titre
donc vous le savez déjà
je vais faire cette vidéo avec
Amixem
J'enlève ce pull que vous
voyez beaucoup trop souvent
en ce moment,
j'enfile une veste
et c'est parti !
[Musique Générique]
Donc l'idée, maintenant,
c'est d'apprendre comment faire
à Amixem
et vous apprenez en même temps.
J'avais déjà fait ce type de vidéo
pour vous apprendre à déterminer
quel jour de la semaine
tombait n'importe quelle date de l'année,
j'avais fait ça l'année dernière,
en 2016.
[Fabien] tu vois, je l'avais sorti en vidéo.
[Amixem] D'accord.
[Fab] Elle a bien, bien bien marché...
euh...
trois ou quatre cents vues déjà...
[Amixem] Ouais...
[Fab] C'était au tout début de la chaîne.
[Amix]Donc c'était du buzz.
[Fab] Ouaiiiis
[Amix] Avant que...
[Fab] Quatre cents vues...
[Fab] Quatre cents vues,
[Amix] Wouhaou...
[Fab] et là, il y avait un 7 et un 5. C'est tout.
[Amix - Petit rire]
[Fab] Ça vaut vraiment le coup de le refaire
cette année
et en plus, comme on vient de passer
une année bissextile,
on repart sur un cycle de 4 ans,
[Amix]D'accord.
[Fab] et, avec cette méthode là,
ça te permet de tenir les 4 ans.
[Fab] Il n'y a pas moins clair que ce
[Amix] D'accord, ok, ok,
[Fab] je viens d'expliquer.
[Amix] j'ai compris, j'ai compris.
[Amix] C'est à dire que là,
ma technique, elle est bonne pour 4 ans,
[Amix] c'est ça ?                   Ok.
[Fab] Exact !
[Fab] Il y a deux choses à apprendre
Amixem, de la chaîne Maxime,
ou l'inverse,
c'est toi qui décide,
il y a deux choses qu'il faut
que tu saches faire.
[Amix] Oui ?
[Fab] Et après tu seras capable de le faire.
Première chose :
j'ai besoin de vérifier
une partie de ta table de 7.
[Fab] 7 fois 1 ?
[Fab] 7
[Amix] C'est ça...
[Fab] 7 x 2 ?
[Amix] 14
[Fab] 3 x 7 ?
[Amix] 21
[Fab] 4 x 7 ?
[Amix] Euh.... vingt... huit.
[Fab] Et ouais...
[Fab] Et bé, tu vois,
je sentais que tu galérais après,
et ben on s'arrête là.
[Amixem] Là... là, on était en mode calcul.
[Fab] Ouais.
[Amix] 7 x 7
49, parce que Maine-et-Loire.
[Fab] Hé !
[Amix] La patrie !
[Fab] Ta deuxième étape :
J'ai un code à te faire apprendre.
[Amix] Oui.
[Fab] Ce code là, on va le créer
en prenant tous les premiers lundi
de chaque mois de l'année.
[Amix] D'accord.
[Fab] De 2017.
[Fab] Par exemple, le premier lundi
du mois de janvier
[Amix - Approbateur] Hmm, Hmm
[Fab] tombait le 1.
[Amix] D'accord.
[Fab] Donc notre code va commencer par 1.
[Fab] Vous n'avez pas forcément besoin
de le retenir dès le départ,
vous pouvez le marquer quelque part,
l'avoir en bidoche...
Mais ça se retient facilement
si on retient par groupe de 3.
[Fab]Donc ça commence par 155
[Amix] 155
[Amix] Ouais...
[Fab] Le deuxième c'est 274.
[Amix] Le deuxième c'est 274,
et bien il y a deux Savoie.
[Fab] Il y a deux Savoie, ouais...
[Amix] 74, Savoie
[Fab] Tu vois, moi, dans ma tête
j'ai pris 2, parce que c'est le deuxième groupe
[Amix] Ouais.
[Fab] ça me va
et 74, ben, je pense à Paris
mais je sais qu'il y a un moins
quelque part qui traîne...
Donc 274, pour le mois
numéro 4, 5 et 6.
[Fab] Donc, avril, mai, juin.
[Amix] avril, mai, juin.
[Fab] Celui d'après, c'est... 263
[Amix] D'accord. Euh...
[Fab] Alors là, il y a un côté un peu facile
moi je trouve.
[Fab] C'est le même 2 que le premier,
[Amix] Oui.
[Fab] et après c'est 74 moins 1 à chaque fois.
[Fab] 7 ça passe 6 et 4 passe à 3.
[Amix] D'accord.
[Fab] Et le dernier c'est,
euh...
[Amix] 153 : il y a une Mayenne.
[Fab] Une Mayenne.
[Amix] J'aime beaucoup les départements,
tu sais ?
[Fab] Maintenant que tu as bien
assimilé ça,
je vais vérifier que
je ne t'ai pas dit de conneries
parce que j'ai juste regardé vite fait
avant de faire la vidéo,
[Amix] Ouais, c'est ce que je...
[RIRES]
[Amix] Alors là, par contre,
pour défaire mon truc...
[Fab] Tu vois...
[Amix] Tu m'as appris des conneries...
[Fab] Alors... 2017....
[Fab] Non ! 2016 ! Pu****
Là j'ai eu peur, j'avais tout faux !
Mais j'étais sur 2017...
Euh...
Non, ben si 2017 !
On est en 2017 ?
[Amix] Oui, oui. C'est le cas.
[Fab] Haaan ! Mais non,
mais alors pas du tout...
[Fab] Mais qu'est-ce que j'ai fait ?
[Amix] Moi j'ai adoré cette vidéo
[Amix] je reviendrai quand vous voulez.
[Fab] Ah, mais non !
[Fab] Je te l'ai fait sur 2018
[Rires]
[Amix]C'est bien, c'est bien !
[Fab] C'est 2018 que j'ai appris !
[Fab] On fait avec le code de 2018,
[Amix] Voilà...
[Fab] et ça ne vous empêchera pas
pour le faire pour 2017
et 2019, et 2020.
[Fab] Elle est valable pour les quatre ans,
[Amix] D'accord.
[Fab] mais on part sur une création,
via 2018
[Fab] au lieu de le faire via 2017...
[Amix] D'accord. Ok, ok...
[Fab] Voilà, c'est tout,
[Amix] La table est basée
[Fab] faut le savoir.
[Amix] sur 2018, c'est juste ça.
[Fab] Mais du coup, c'est vraiment pété
d'avoir fait ça.
[Fab] Mais euh... 155 c'est bon,
274, n'est-ce pas ?
Euh...
263, on est bon...
et 153
Donc au moins je ne m'étais pas gouré,
c'est les premiers lundis de 2018 !
[Amix] Très bien. C'est :
[Amix]  155
[Fab] Ouais
[Amix]  274
[Amix]  263
[Fab] Ouais
[Amix]  et 153
[Fab] Si je te demande quel est
le premier lundi du mois d'octobre ?
[Amix] Alors là, euh....
mmmmm...
C'est 1.
[Fab] Exact.
[Fab] Donc en fait dans ta tête, en temps normal,
tu vois un peu les paquets par 3
[Amix] Ouais.
[Fab] Et tu te repères dedans...
[Amix] Faudrait que j'apprenne
les paquets de mois aussi...
[Rires]
[Amix] Ça serait pas mal.
[Fab] Le premier lundi de juillet ?
[Amix]Euh...
le premier lundi de juillet
effectivement,
on peut en parler, hein...
euh...
attends, attends...
Pu****
Septembre, août, euh....
[Amix] Juillet... ouais
[Fab] Ouais
[Amix] Donc c'est l'avant dernier paquet, hein...
très connu parce que c'est le 263
et que c'est lundi 2.
[Fab] Exactement.
[Amix - Soupir de soulagement]
[Fab] Tu auras la gymnastique
d'aller chercher, en fait,
quel est le jour où tombre
le premier lundi de chaque mois.
[Amix] Oui.
[Fab] Et après tu vas utiliser ta table de 7.
[Fab] Imaginons : tu es né quel jour ?
[Amix] Je suis né le 4.
[Fab] Le 4 ?                        Mars.
[Amix] Mars.
[Amix] Ouais
[Fab] Donc le 4 / 03
[Amix] Oui
[Fab] Le 4 / 03, en 2018
puisque c'est la table 2018,
on va savoir quand est-ce que ça tombe.
[Amix] Hmm, hmm.
[Fab] Assez facilement,
[Fab] puisque...
[Amix] Je suis très content d'être né le 4, là, du coup.
[Rires]
[Fab] Donc le premier lundi du mois de mars,
c'est quand ?
[Amix] Le premier lundi du mois de mars c'est...
euh.... le 5 ?
[Amix] Donc ce serait un dimanche.
[Fab]Exactement.
[Amix] En famille ! Ce sera bien.
[Fab] Ce sera la veille.
[Amix] Ouais.
[Fab] Donc là c'était simple,
parce que c'était le 4.
[Amix] Exact.
[Fab] Donc tu as pu accéder
à l'information tout de suite.
[Fab] Et pour 2017, ça tombera quand
du coup ?
[Amix] Euh....
[Fab] Et bien, un jour avant.
[Fab] Puisque là tu es sur la table
de  2018.
[Amix] Oh, le con.
[Amix] Donc ce sera un samedi, d'accord ?
[Fab] Ouais
[Fab] En fait, comme vous apprenez
la table 2018 directement,
dites vous que, quand vous arrivez au jour,
vous remontez un jour en arrière
[Fab] pour avoir le jour de 2017,
[Amix] Ok
et quand on sera en 2019
si vous voulez chercher pour 2019,
vous faites 1 jour après.
et 2020, deux jours après.
[Amix] Ok.
[Fab] C'est pour ça qu'on s'en fout en fait
de la table, où est-ce qu'elle est placée
[Amix] Ok.
[Fab] Ça fait ta référence pour 2018.
[Fab] Je veux connaître le
22 novembre 2020.
[Amix] Le 22...
Oh le con !
Alors attends.
Déjà je commence par 2018, hein !
[Fab] Ouais.
[Amix] Euh.... mmmm....
Donc déjà... euh.....
[Fab] Donc on va chercher le 11ème
d'abord.
[Fab] Le 11ème mois.
[Amix] Donc c'est un lundi 5.
[Fab] Exactement.
[Amix] Voilà. Ok.
[Fab] Maintenant, pour aller au 22,
tu vas chercher à additionner,
à rajouter 7 ou 14 ou 21 ou 28
mais sans cramer ta date.
[Amix] Oui, d'accord. Ok, ok.
[Amix] Je rajoute 14, donc 19...
[Fab] Voilà. Tu vas rajouter le 14,
ça te met 19
[Amix - Approbateur] Hmmm, hmmm.
[Fab] Donc tu sais que
[Fab] le lundi 19 novembre 2018
[Amix] que le 19 est un lundi
[Fab] enfin... que le 19 novembre 2018 est un lundi.
[Amix] Oui.
[Fab] Et après, tu y vas en tâtonnant.
[Fab] Et là, je vous le dis :
aidez-vous des doigts !
[Fab] Lundi 19, mardi 20...
[Amix] Mardi 22,
[Amix] mercredi 23, jeudi vingt...
[Fab - Riant] Mais non...
[Amix] 24
[Fab]Lundi 19 !
[Amix] Ah oui, 19 ! Merde !
[Fab] Mardi 20...
[Fab] Mardi 20.
[Amix] Mardi 20,
[Fab] mercredi 21,
[Amix] 21,
[Fab] Jeudi ?                  22.
[Amix]   22
[Fab] Donc tu sais que c'est un jeudi.
[Amix] Pu****
[Fab] 2018, c'est un jeudi.
[Fab] En 2017, c'est un mercredi.
[Amix] Oui.
[Fab] En 2019, c'est un vendredi.
[Amix] Oui
[Fab] Et en 2020, c'est un samedi.
[Amix] Yes !
[Fab] Est-ce que tu te sens capable,
maintenant, de le faire ?
[Amix] Ouais, ouais.
Tu me laisses un peu de temps...
[Fab] Ouais
[Amix] et on est bon.
[Fab] Allez, je balance une date comme ça...
[Amix] Vers le début du mois s'il te plaît.
[Rires]
[Fab] Je vais te balancer un petit
18 août 2017
[Amix] C'est gentil...
[Fab] 18 août 2017
[Amix] C'est gentil.
[Amix] Hummm... Août, on est sur du...
euh...
sur le fameux...
je l'ai déjà oublié ce con...
c'est le 263...
euh...
le 263 et c'est du coup, le...
le.. le 6
Donc c'est un lundi 6 ?
[Amix] Tu ne me confirmes rien ?
[Fab] Ah ? Rien !
[Amix] Ah merde...
euh...
ouais, si... c'est ça...
euh... oh, là, là...
Attends 'tends 'tends 'tends 'tends 'tends 'tends...
[Amix] 6 ! Donc c'est le 6 août.
[Fab] Tu vois, tu pouvais te faire confiance,
[Fab] tu avais bon.
[Amix] Ok !
[Amix] Donc, lundi 6 et tu veux que
j'aille au 18 ?
[Fab] Oui, s'il vous plaît...
[Amix] Avec grand plaisir.
[Fab] Sans vous commander !
[Amix] 6, lundi 6.
Donc euh...
Lundi 6 + 14 ça devrait...
...pas le faire.
Si, ça devrait le faire,
mais c'est deux jours avant.
[Amix] Euh....
[Fab] ça te ferait le 20 en tout cas...
[Amix] Ça te ferait un lundi 20...
[Fab] Mais peut-être que tu peux remonter en arrière...
[Amix] Ouais, ouais, ça devrait le faire,
ça je pense, légallement on peut le faire
donc ce serait un samedi 18...
euh... août 2017,
on sera en famille,
ce sera l'été, ce sera pas mal...
[Fab] Est-ce que tu es sûr de toi ?
[Amix] Euh......
[Fab] Moi je te demande en 2017,
tu me dis que c'est un samedi en 2017 ?
[Amix] Samedi 18 août ?
Attends 'tends 'tends, je te le confirme...
[Amix] Euh....                c'est un 19 ?
[Fab] N'oublie pas que je t'ai pété en...
[Fab] ... en t'apprenant la table de 2018
[Amix] C'est vrai ça, pu****
[Fab] Donc en fait c'est vrai pour 2018,
ce sera un samedi en 2018.
[Amix] Donc ce serait un vendredi ?
[Fab] Ouais, ça serait un vendredi en 2017
[Amix] ce serait un vendredi, pu*****, me***
[Fab] Est-ce que tu te sens capable de le faire
de temps en temps, cette gymnastique mentale ?
[Amix] Je suis capable de le faire,
en plus, surtout que...
genre, ce qui m'a fait perdre du temps,
notamment, c'est de retrouver
le groupement de chiffres.
[Fab] Ouais, c'est ça.
[Amix] Une fois que tu l'as,
[Amix] ...je pense que tu gagnes
beaucoup de temps.
Et puis quand tu as été à l'école,
du coup tu connais ta table de 7...
[Fab] Exactement !
[Amix] Et là... c'est cadeau.
[Fab] Mais il faut juste s'entraîner un petit peu.
La preuve !
Et plus vous allez le faire,
et meilleurs vous êtes, quoi.
J'espère que vous avez bien compris
toutes les étapes :
Apprendre le code
de 2017 ou 2018.
Une fois qu'on vous donne une date,
trouver le premier lundi du mois correspondant.
Se rapprocher le plus possible de la date
en rajoutant 7, 14, 21 ou 28.
C'est à dire un multiple de 7.
Et finir par tâtonnement
de trouver le jour exact.
Si vous avez appris le code de 2018,
pour avoir le jour de 2017,
ben, vous ferez un jour en moins ;
de 2019, un jour en plus ;
et si celle-ci vous a plu,
comme d'habitude, vous likez,
vous vous abonnez,
Et si jamais, vous avez le malheur
de ne pas connaître Amixem,
vous pouvez cliquer
sur le lien dans le descriptif,
ou sur le petit rond qui va apparaître ici
parce qu'il
[Fab] ne reste plus que 20 secondes
de vidéo à partir de maintenant
[Amix] Ouais, je le vois, je le vois
[Amix] Un grand plaisir, j'ai envie de dire...155,
[Fab] ... on se sert les mains !
274, 163, euh....
pu***, me*** ... 153 ! La Mayenne.
[Fab] Yeeesss !
[Amix] La Mayenne !!!
[Fab] Trop bien !
[Amix] Merci !
[Fab] Ciao.
[Amix] Salut.
[Musique Générique de fin]